字幕: Kyoko Kamura
校正: Koichiro YODA
こんにちは
（客席）こんにちは
さっそく自己紹介をしようかなと
思うんですけど
僕 自己紹介がちょっと苦手でして
難しくないですか？
そういう時に
肩書きって便利ですよね
きっと みなさんの名刺にも社長とか
どうでしょう
○○リーダーとか ○○担当とか
○○大臣とかいらっしゃいませんか？
大丈夫ですか？
あとは デザイナー エンジニア
ライターみたいに
職種を書いている方も
いるかもしれないし
主婦とか学生みたいなのも
もちろん立派な肩書きだと思います
それが書いた名刺を
「私はこういう者です」と
渡すわけですけど
僕はいつもモヤモヤするんですね
あれ？ これどれくらい
自分伝わってるのかな？みたいな
「よろしくお願いします」
んーどうかなー？みたいな
肩書きってそもそも必要なのかな？
何なのかな？
そんな肩書きの
そもそものところから
僕の話を始められたらなと
思っています
ということで 遅れましたが
勉強家の兼松佳宏と申します
よろしくお願いします
（拍手）
もう帰りたくなった方
いらっしゃいませんか？
なんか変な人いますよ
（笑）
でも 安心してくださいって
言ったら変ですけど
一応 京都精華大学という大学で
大学教員をしています
あるいは その前はですね
「greenz.jp」という
ウェブマガジンの編集長をしていました
そうですね あとは
２つのNPOの理事もしています
変わったところで言うと
この秋からですね
山梨県の身延町という町の
観光大使を務めることになりました
ちょっと安心しましたか？
大学教員とか 編集長とか
理事とか 観光大使って言われると
「あぁ なんかそれなりにやってる人
なのかな」みたいなことですかね
今 言ったのって 役職とか
何をしているかってことだと
思うんですけど
僕は それを
「doの肩書き」と呼んでいます
「する」のdoですね
じゃあ 勉強家って
なんやねん と言うと
僕は勉強することが
大好きな人なんですっていう
「こんな人です」というのを
表すための肩書きなんです
それを僕は「be動詞」のbeで
「beの肩書き」と呼んでいます
それを図にするとこんな感じです
そのdoとbeが敵対しているとか
そういうことでは決してなくて
いま世の中であるものとか
外から見えるもの
島になっているものが
「doの肩書き」だとすれば
それを島たらしめているマグマが
その下にあるはずなんですよ
噴火してボコってね
それが島になっている
そのマグマの部分を「beの肩書き」と
呼びたいなと思っているんです
で それが僕にとっては
「勉強家」なんですね
僕がその勉強家って
名乗り始めたのは もう10周年
今40歳なんですけど
ちょうど30歳のときでした
少し僕の肩書きの歴史なんですけど
20代はですね その肩書きを
すごく悩んだ10年だったんですね
一番最初にもらった肩書は
「ウェブデザイナー」でした
格好良くないですか？
ウェブデザイナー
この中にもいらっしゃるかもしれません
僕 ぶっちゃけ
秋田生まれの田舎者でして
地元に帰ったら
ちやほやされるような
そんな仕事がしたかったんですね
もう「デザイナー最高！」と
思って憧れてたんです
で 念願叶って
ウェブデザイナーになりました
夢が叶いました
けど そこから悩み始めるんですね
ウェブデザイナーであることが
当たり前になって２年目
「本当にこれをやりたかったのかな？」
そんなクエスチョンが
浮かんできたんです
で ちょっと思うところがあって
転職したとき
24歳で転職したときは
「アートディレクター」
ちょっと出世しましたよね
けど 社員４人しかいないのに
デザイナーひとり
セルフディレクションです（笑）
ね 言ったもん勝ちみたいな
そのさらに２年後
フリーランスとして独立します
そのときの肩書きがこちらです
「チーフ・スピリチュアル・オフィサー」
大出世ですよ！ 大出世
詳しくは割愛します
さらに２年後 「greenz」という
さっきメールマガジン言いましたが
そこに正式に関わるときには
「クリエイティブディレクター
／ デザインジャーナリスト」
ね カッコいい！
さらにその２年後
30歳のときにはですね
ここまできましたよ
「コンテンツディレクター
／ グリーンジャーナリスト」
まぁ 節操なく とっかえひっかえ
それっぽい横文字の
肩書きを並べてきました
「兼松さん これ長いの削って
いいですか？」みたいなこともありました
で なんでこんなふうに
いっぱい変えてきたかというと
自分的にはですね
発破をかけたかったんです
「俺はこれになるんだ！
だから これを名乗って
もっともっと成長するんだ」
それを上のところでとっかえひっかえ
やってきたわけですけども
あるとき 自分が言ってることと
自分ができてることに
何かギャップを感じるように
なったんですね
正直 半年間全く仕事ができない
鬱っぽくなってしまって
仕事を休んだ時期もありました
その時はこんな感じです
「私は何者なんだろう？」
「何がしたかったんだろう？」
これが30歳のときです
で 転機となったのが
「勉強家」というキーワード
だったんですね
それは 友人からふと言われた
一言だったんです
僕「ヨッシュ」って呼ばれてるんですけど
「ヨッシュってさ
いっつも勉強してるよね
勉強大好き 勉強家だね」と
言われたわけです
人から言われる言葉ですよね
勉強家って
最初 僕は「あ 馬鹿にされてる」と
思ったわけです
「ん？ これはどっちだ？」みたいな
でも 本気で言ってくれてるし
僕自身なんかこう —
「これ一番今まででしっくりくる
自分の呼び方 肩書きかも」って
ピンときたんです
すごくカチッとハマった気がしたんですね
「うわ これがあったらもう
上は何でもいいんじゃないかな」って
それぐらい思いました
で 「勉強家」っていうのはですね
友人からのプレゼントだったわけです
けれども それが僕にとって かなり
大きな意味を持ち始めて人生を変えます
勉強家には いろんな意味を
込めているんですけども
１つ目は 本当に好奇心の赴くままに
いろんなものを読んだりしているんですね
空海の本を読んだり
ソーシャルデザインの本を読んだり
で 色々やってるとですね
「あれ？ これとこれが
ここで繋がるじゃん！」みたいな
一筋の光が見えてきたりする
その時にザワザワザワと
全身に鳥肌がたつ
それが勉強家にとっての
醍醐味のひとつです
あるいは 僕は勉強家なので
専門家には勝てません
けど 一生懸命チャレンジします
実験もして失敗もたくさんして
できるようになろうとする
永遠のアマチュアなんですね
というのも 編集長と言いましたが
編集未経験で編集長やりました
大学教員と言うてますが
僕 修士号持っていません
全て一から試行錯誤して
なんとか形にしていく
でも 専門家じゃないからこそ
アマチュアだからこそ
打ち出せる新鮮な価値ってのも
やっぱりあるんですよね
それまでは「なんて中途半端な
自分なんだろう」って
自分をコンプレックスで
責めてたんですけども
そうではなくて これは
「いろんなことにチャレンジしたい」
そういう在り方なんだっていうふうに
勉強家と名付けたことで
自己肯定できるようになったんです
僕は今 もうすぐ40歳で
京都精華大学との契約も
あと２年で終わるんですね
さて この後どうしようって
ことなんですけども
もしかしたら 起業するかもしれないし
就職活動ちゃんとするだろうし
あるいは 誰かから「一緒にやらない？」と
声をかけて頂けるかもしれません
もしかしたら スナックを
経営してるかもしれないし
高野山でお坊さんに
なってるかもしれない
でも そこで一番大事にしたいのは
このど真ん中の「勉強家」である自分が
喜びを感じられるかどうか？
その問いをずっと
持ち続けていたいなと思っています
まあ ビービービービー（be）言ってね
けど これ決してdoの肩書きを
否定しているわけではないんです
むしろbeの肩書きと同じくらい
doの肩書きも大事ですね
doという島の部分で
どうマグマを発揮するのか
ひとり素敵な方を
ご紹介したいと思います
その方はですね 京都市の
バスの運転手さんなんですけども
本当に車内アナウンスが
面白いんですよ
色々ネタがあってですね
僕が真似するとつまらなくなるので
ちょっと辛抱して頂きたいんですけど
ひとつだけご披露すると
「えー みなさん 最近は忘れ物が
多くなっておりますのでご注意ください
最近多い忘れ物は
携帯電話、傘、財布…」
まぁ ありそうですよね
「イヤホン、ペン…」
なんかちょっと細かいな
「ガラケー…」
ん？なんかちょっと細かすぎないかな
「iPhone 11、iPhone 11 Pro
iPhone 11 Pro Max…」
いやいやいや そこまで？！みたいな
あとですね「パーカー、処方箋の袋…」
あ 処方箋の袋！ おばあちゃーん！みたいな
なんかこう情景が浮かびますよね
そういうの30個くらい
列挙したりして
すごい車内がドッカンドッカン
笑い 包まれるわけですけど
そのバスの運転手さんは
夜な夜な もしかしたら
ネタ番組とかお笑い番組を見て
来年はどんな新しいネタを
作ろうかなって
研究してるかもしれないですよね
わかんないですけど
けど その彼にとっての
最高の晴れ舞台というのは
劇場でもテレビでもなくて
「バスの中」なんです
同じように この中でもしかしたら
小説家になりたいって思ってる方
いるかもしれませんが
その方がもし保育士さんを
しているとすれば
毎週 絵本を作って
子供達に読み聞かせをする
そんなのも素敵かもしれません
けど それが100冊ぐらいなったら
本当に出版社さんから
「出版しませんか？」て
来るかもしれないですよね
コメディアンのような
バスの運転手さん
小説家のような保育士さん
このdoの肩書きとbeの肩書きを掛け算
この交わるところが
その人の個性であり
その人にしかできない
働き方なんじゃないかなと
僕は思っています
なので「beの肩書きを見つけた！
じゃあ 今の仕事を辞めるわ」とか
そういうことでは決してなくて
「こういうbeの肩書きがあるから
今これをやれてるんだなぁ」
「あぁ これで良かったなぁ」みたいに
今の仕事を愛せるようになる
そんなのも 僕の願いです
でね「じゃあ beの肩書きって
どうやって見つけたらいいの？」って
思った方いるかもしれませんが
最後に３つの問いを皆さんに
プレゼントできたらなと思います
１つ目は 自分にとっては
ごくごく当たり前のことなんだけども
なんだか周りからやたら「すごいね」って
言われることありませんか？
僕だったらこうやって
人前で話すみたいなのは
「え みんなできるんじゃないの？」って
思うわけですけど そうではないらしい
たとえば イラスト上手な人が
いるじゃないですか
みんなイラスト上手だって
思ってますよね
「いや 僕はそんなことないし」みたいな
つまり 得意技って
自分では意外とわかってなくて
当たり前にできることを
他の人に教えてもらう
「それってすごいんだよ」って
教えてもらうことって
すごい大事なんじゃないかなと
思っています
それが１つ目
２つ目は
「こんな瞬間が続いてほしいなぁ」って
しみじみ思うことってどういうことですか？
僕のbeの肩書きは
「勉強家」もありますが
あと「コメディアン」って 多分
そういう成分もありそうなんですよね
で そのコメディアン成分の僕にとっては
ちょっと笑っていただけたりすると
「あぁやって良かったなぁ」って
思うわけです
笑ってもらうことで
自分は花ひらく
だから 大学の授業っていうのも
自分にとってはすごく楽しい
時間なのかなぁと思ったりしています
あと ３つ目はですね
人から何かを頼まれた時に
「あ それならお役に立てそうだなぁ」
「自分の力を十分に
発揮できそうだなぁ」
そう思うようなことって
どういうことでしょうか？
僕で言うと 左右の眼の
視力の差が激しすぎて
立体感覚がない人間なんですね
そうすると完全に（釘を）打ち間違えます
自分の親指を打ってしまいます
だから DIYは
僕は戦力にならないので
声をかけないでくださいって
言っちゃうんですけど
「じゃあ結婚式の司会やって」
「おぉ もう喜んでやるよ！」みたいなね
そんな感じです
今 言ったみたいな
３つの問いですね
自分にとっては
当たり前なんですけども
なんか周りからやたら「すごいね」って
言われることって何ですか？
「こんな時間がずっと続けばいいなぁ」と
しみじみ思うことは何でしょうか？
人から頼まれた時に
「こんなことならすぐできるよ」
「力を発揮できそう」と
思うことは何でしょうか？
そんな深い 自分と向き合える問いを
持って頂きながら
ぜひ皆さんも「beの肩書き」を
探求して頂けたらなと思います
勉強家の兼松でした
ありがとうございました
（拍手）